it takes innovative thinking pairing
non-traditional experiences or products
or processes with what is traditional
and seeing if something could work out
and having the resiliency to carry
through because what we have right now
is not working the number one issue is
that right now today would be
affordability and how cities are
becoming unaffordable all around the
world there's so many new things
happening around technology artificial
intelligence machine learning 3d
printing are all areas of research that
can contribute to we need just in
America 20 million houses by 2025
the housing Innovation Lab was created
three years ago by Mayor Walsh to help
reduce the cost of housing in Boston by
testing new strategies for producing
housing the house that is put together
using just one tool a hex wrench one of
the things we're trying to do at Fannie
Mae is to build a platform where people
can test and learn they can experiment
and see what doesn't work and what does
work I know that the best idea is one I
haven't even heard of yet and I know
those are the ideas that unleash an
enormous value in housing and elsewhere
you know when we started people told us
no one's ever gonna get a mortgage on my
mobile phone and today we're seeing that
that's clearly not true I work with
major banks now and I think five years
ago that was unthinkable that's progress
right there
so you have an entire generation
expecting an ague / top experience they
don't expect the wolf canto Kinko's and
the facts they're back same duty
we've created an airtight security
platform to allow this data to be
transferred the mortgage business is
fundamentally rooted in 50 years ago
rules and technologies and so there's a
lot of low-hanging fruit here to fix as
we go on our mission of trying to make
the cost of delivering credit cheaper
and we can do that then the cost of
credit and ultimately the cost of
housing gets cheaper that's the mission
honey may happens to be one of the most
tech forwarding companies I understand
they are thinking about things that
Silicon Valley or a legislator started
to get on top of there are really
scientific about blockchain and the
applications are really starting to
think about how this actually affects
accessibility
[Music]
by working on software that decomposes a
design of a house of 3d shape into 3000
parts that are then later cut by CAD CAM
or cut by machinery and put together
with human labor with direct
manufacturing Co computers you should be
able to calculate time and cost and
materials a lot better for the longest
time individuals thought that you could
never Paris expensive solar panels or
new systems in with affordable housing
discover it not only is it financially
feasible it's actually enhancing to the
bottom line so Finance ears designers
innovators entrepreneurs we all have a
role to play the world is what we make
it we're thinking like futurists looking
at the problems that we have today for
affordable housing
I always think Nelson Mandela actually
he quoted like the greatest risk is
actually looking on the problem that's
too small and so I think like for
innovation for me means exactly that
innovation to me means aids safer faster
cheaper more accessible housing finance
system and if we can deliver that by
partnering with innovators around the
country we will it succeed in an Amish
[Music]
good morning Wow students never replied
when I say good morning as many of you
may be aware parking is a little bit
difficult in Cambridge especially around
MIT with so much construction so we have
an over sold audience today there's a
few more seats but we're expecting
standing room at some point so it's been
a fantastic turnout my name is Alan
burger I'm a professor here in the
Department of urban studies and planning
and I'm also the co-director of the
Norman B Leventhal Centre for advanced
urbanism and I'd like to welcome you on
behalf of the center in on behalf of MIT
for those of you who well I should say I
you know usually start this off again
with students please turn off your
phones and usually I say don't eat
celery during the event but if you could
please just turn remind yourself to turn
your phones on silent mode for those of
you who may be new to the Leventhal
Centre for advanced urbanism our role at
MIT is to be the convener of all things
urban within the ecosystem of the
Institute our mission is to solve the
most complex urban problems doing so we
form interdisciplinary teams across the
five schools at MIT knowing that one
expert simply is not going to be enough
to solve the complexity of our urban
challenges today's topic affordable
housing is one such complex topic that
needs a lot more investigation and this
hopefully is an event where we can look
locally at the Boston issues but also
think of this in the context of the
global and even the national affordable
housing problem and I only point that
out because as you walked in you walked
through and that
submission that our Center recently put
on as part of a biennial theme about
global affordable housing or what we
call housing plus and what that means we
looked at many locations around the
world I invite you to spend some time
down in the lobby looking at the case
studies while you're here and some of
the videos that are also on the wall of
running they're up and running so and if
you're interested please speak to any of
the center staff members who are hosting
the event outside or myself if you
happen to catch me out there
our next biennial theme I wanted to
mention is called equitable resilience
and I know everyone who's local is now
about to jump out of their seats because
this is a topic Boston cares deeply
about what does resilience mean in the
sense of equitability for all citizens
we will spend the next two years working
on this with faculty across MIT and the
point of this is to really look at what
does resilience mean when you're
fortifying a city whether it's for heat
or flooding or coastal resilience or
social resilience what does it mean to
have equitability for all citizens not
just building flood walls in the
wealthiest parts of cities to protect
people who have many of their own
resources to either move or find safety
if you're interested locally I know
there's a lot of Cambridge folks there's
a lot of other cities here that are
represented here in the Boston region if
you're interested in getting involved in
equitable resilience this is just
starting and please please find me if
you'd like to get involved we want to
work with communities locally and we
will so you could be the first ones in
and help us build the program now I want
to mention just one more thing which is
downstairs represents our international
view of affordable housing in some of
the work we've done over the last
several years today we're really make
you'd shift into not just the United
States but here locally in the Boston
region and I'd like to welcome our the
sponsor of today's event Fannie Mae to
MIT they brought a lot of people from
Fannie Mae and they're gonna work with
us they worked with us on this program
for a number of months and we think it's
a very thoughtful program and it's well
balanced on a number of topics that
we're going to present we'd also like to
extend a warm welcome to all of you from
the region who have given up your day
there's a lot going on here the mayor's
conference wrapping up and those of you
who are on the frontlines of affordable
housing this is a very difficult serious
deep deep problem in communities around
the region today is organized in a it's
not a typical academic kind of
presentation format we're going to panel
discussions there'll be a few small
videos in a couple of very short
presentations but largely it's a
conversational format where you can get
involved also in some of the
question-and-answer sessions we're gonna
really just focus in on what is housing
an affordable affordability mean for the
Boston area
the first panel is going to look at
Boston specifically as we explore what's
behind the supply crisis we all may have
our opinions about this but our experts
hope to dive a little bit deeper into
this later in the morning we're going to
hear about it technology innovations
advancements in different kinds and
forms of technology that will help
hopefully the affordability issue it
will be sort of followed by this future
focused panels so we have three panels
we're gonna have a few minutes of Q&A
after each panel and I would ask that
you please participate it always makes
an event better when we have some
audience participation and if I have to
what I would do in a classroom setting
I would like to prod you I will ask you
I will just I'll just jump in and I'll
say please jump in
our moderators are going to introduce
the panelists so this may be the last
time you see me here unless I feel a
need to jump in and interrupt to get
some more interaction so again I want to
thank you and I'm going to introduce the
keynote in a minute but but first before
I do that I'd like to introduce somebody
who's going to also welcome you here the
other thing I want to mention is there's
little breaks in between the panels
where we're gonna have five-minute
vignettes so it's a little bit less
formal than academic setting panels
five-minute vignette panel five-minute
vignette where someone's going to share
their research here in a different sort
of format so it'll be a nice sort of
give-and-take
so before I introduce our keynote I'd
like to invite up the president and CEO
of Fannie Mae Tim my appleís who is
going to welcome you on behalf of Fannie
Mae Tim
[Applause]
Thank You Alan
it's great to be back here at MIT at
Fannie Mae we have a number of
relationships with with MIT truly a
great institution and it's terrific to
be here today with you all and it's
particularly a pleasure to be here
sponsoring this program with the Center
for advanced urbanism we're really quite
appreciative of all the terrific work
that you all are doing at Fannie Mae
we're really dedicated to expanding
affordable sustainable homeownership and
rental housing in the United States and
it's truly an exciting time to be in
housing in America there's so much going
on in terms of transformation of the
housing markets in the housing finance
system we're seeing things like slow
very paper-based processes giving way to
new digital processes that are really I
think going to radically change how we
go about financing housing in the United
States we have things like automation
artificial intelligence big data all
these things are changing the way we
think about housing and housing finance
at the same time there are new design
principles and techniques materials
around housing itself including
prefabrication things like 3d printing
it was fabulous I was in Austin a few
weeks ago and saw the first permitted 3d
printed house in the United States and
really remarkable you can see how the
world's gonna change there's some very
significant fundamental ways our housing
markets in the wake of the great
financial crisis have been come stronger
and safer and that's all very good but
all these promising developments are
against a backdrop of a very significant
challenge that we're seeing in the
country in many American communities
housing affordability has really become
a crisis for many people it's a crisis
that's driven by legal financial
regulatory and economic currents that
have been in play for quite a long time
but now we're really seeing them
manifest
themselves and all this is taking place
within a legacy housing system we have a
system that was really designed to need
to meet the needs of the greatest
generation but now as being a challenge
to meet the needs of generations x and y
and z and as we emerge from the
financial crisis for example mortgages
became much safer and more sustainable
and yet we have to do more to give
greater access to credit to creditworthy
borrowers today's borrowers of today's
renters come for a much more diverse set
of backgrounds both economically and
demographically more than any other in
the history of our country and many are
burdened by things that we haven't seen
in the past there's their burden by
student debt many of them are working in
a gig economy it's very difficult they
are essentially cobbling together
careers for themselves
technology and innovation are opening up
new mortgage and rental options for
today's borrowers and renters but these
new products and new thinking thinking
will ring hollow if we don't address the
fundamental underlying issue which is
the supply of affordable housing the
current housing recovery has taken place
much more on the high end of the market
than on the affordable end and homes
that are affordable and accessible to
first-time homebuyers have actually
diminished since the financial crisis
rather than increased and frankly at
this point close to half of all
households are all renters in the United
States our cost bird and that is they
spend more than a third of their income
on rent and utilities so affordable
housing has really become a significant
challenge in our time and meeting this
challenge will require our best ideas
our best talent and many many hands on
the job so it's going to require private
sector moxie and innovation it's going
to require capital markets that are
ready to fuel those innovations and it's
going to require a policy and regulatory
environment that
that accepts and welcomes intelligent
risk-taking and new ideas so fortunately
there are representatives of all three
of those disciplines here in the room
both in terms of the people who will be
on our panels and in our audience and
we're really proud at Fannie Mae to
share our experiences here but more
fundamentally to listen and learn from
all of you to try to help address these
issues we hope that today will lead to a
conversation that will help address an
issue that really is vital to our
country it's absolutely imperative that
we start to develop a national housing
policy but frankly much of that policy
is going to take place at the at the at
the local level that's where things
really get done that's where things can
really happen so we look forward to
today's conversation I want to thank you
all for being here I'm going to turn
things back to Alan who's going to
introduce our keynote speaker thank you
[Applause]
thanks Tim I'd like to now introduce the
keynote to kick off the morning our
keynote speaker is Krystle Kornegay
she's currently the executive director
of mass housing the independent aged
it's an independent agency created in
1966 that is charged with providing
financing for affordable housing in
Massachusetts prior to mass housing
Krystle served as the Under Secretary
for Housing and Community Development
where she in Massachusetts where she
increased state capital dollars for
affordable housing by 18 percent since
2015 and increased rental subsidies for
low-income families by 42 percent she
also launched a collaborative 100
million dollar work force housing
initiative and worked to streamline the
community investment tax credit program
Krystal is a graduate of the achieving
excellence program at Harvard Kennedy
School I didn't hear any boos so there's
not a lot of ammonia she has a Bachelor
Bachelor of Arts from Hunter College but
of course her most important academic
achievement is receiving her master's
degree in City Planning from MIT School
of Architecture and planning please join
me in welcoming Krystle
[Applause]
alright I'm gonna like her we're gonna
technology here which I might need help
with let's try to see there you go I do
need help with the technology don't
laugh at me Jared I hear you oh great
anyway oh they're for reading not really
distance you guys started to look really
blurry good morning thank you all for
coming and for having me this morning
I'm gonna spend a little bit of time
talking this morning about how the state
has how the state kind of views what the
challenges in terms of housing
affordability and supply and a little
bit about what we've been trying to do
to address that just want to talk first
about mass housing I've been near
probably going over four or five months
now mass housing is the state's
affordable housing bank as Allen
described mass housing has been around
since 1966 and over the past three years
alone we've generated over 1.8 billion
dollars in home mortgages and helped
seventy seven hundred families become
homeowners including three thousand
low-income families purchased purchasing
their first homes of loan 2.2 billion
dollars to developers affordable housing
many of whom are in the room and
preserve the affordability of 3,000
rental units for low-income households
so about two years ago the government
when I was undersecretary the governor
asked a bunch of us interdisciplinary
folks from ANF folks from do our folks
from a to really look at do a little
study about what did we think the cause
of the problem was because everybody
says we have an affordable housing
crisis
but then there were those of us who've
been doing like straight affordable
housing for a long time and it felt like
there's been a crisis and some of what
we had to do through that process was to
educate people who weren't as deeply
steeped in the day-to-day work as we
were so one of the things we discovered
was that supply and demand do matter and
the decades in the 60s 70s and 80s you
can see we were building about 30,000
units
you know annually through those decades
and now we're just building half as much
and so that decrease over the past three
years has really caused a problem in our
supply and that slow production has led
to inflated housing prices as you can
see through this map I mean through this
graph as well as created a costly rental
market which none of this stuff anyone
in this room is gonna be surprised about
the other thing that happens is we live
in a in the state of Massachusetts we
have what we call a home rule and so we
have basically 351 zoning rules every
city in town gets to decide how they
want to build out if they want to build
and if they do what that looks like and
a lot of that has led to kind of sprawl
and so when you think about one acre
zoning we do this little graphic to
understand what that means the other
thing is we realize in Massachusetts
that it takes a super majority to change
local zoning rules and Massachusetts is
one of the one of ten states in the
country and the only state in New
England for which that is true as
opposed to a simple majority and when we
go around and talk to municipal leaders
we often hear we could have got that
project done but for thirteen votes at
Town Meeting and then the real problem
the real thing that I believe raises
this to crisis level is because we're
not building housing anymore for
middle-class we've now got to this place
in which you could make a hundred
$120,000 a year
and can't afford a house and that's a
huge problem for our young people for
our families and even for older folks
who are looking to downsize as you can
see the middle-income cost burden has
spiked over time some of which we were
just talking about before gone from
levels of twenty thirty two percent to
almost fifty percent in metro Boston and
because of that the the cost burdens are
really creating a different kind of City
in Boston moving to a place where we're
having you know really high income
housing and really low income housing
because it can be subsidized and then we
also had to think about there was all
this debate about well who is workforce
housing for what is middle income mean
and that often becomes a challenge when
you talk about affordable right and the
way that salaries are going today you
could be a line cook and the building
maintenance worker raising one child and
you know you're 70 percent of ami an
area meeting income which normally one
would be able to at least find a rental
unit in the marketplace and be able to
afford that no longer can we see those
things those things are harder and
harder to come by
and because middle-income families can't
really afford to live near the near
where they work we're experiencing huge
kind of traffic infrastructure problems
people are on the road longer because if
you want to buy a house you got to drive
till you can afford one and that's
getting further and further away from
the employment center so a couple of
things that the administration did one
was about making sure that whatever we
did we did in partnership with
municipalities and so the governor did
this initiative called promoting housing
choice and wanted to really try to think
about how could we get to
to produce 135,000 new housing units by
2025 so we created a package of
incentives and rewards one of which is
based on the idea that there are
communities doing the things that we
want them to do and that we already have
a host of incentives for communities and
so what we really wanted to do was
reward folks who had been doing high
production over the past five years and
to encourage them to keep doing that and
hold that up as some as something that
communities could strive to the other
thing we realized was there is a lot of
technical assistance across the state
government but if you're an immunity and
you don't know exactly what you want you
got to figure out how to do that and we
wanted to create a way in which you
could get coordinated access to
technical assistance we didn't feel we
didn't want we didn't want you to watch
us make the sausage right we just wanted
to like serve you sausage and the final
thing as part of this initiative the
governor put forth legislation that was
basically lowering that supermajority
bar to a simple majority and not for
everything but for certain good zoning
practices so if you wanted to reduce
your parking requirement in your
downtown you could do that by a simple
majority instead of a supermajority if
you wanted to create accessory dwelling
unit guidelines for your community you
could do that by simple majority not
supermajority or even not by a special
permit I talked about a bunch of this
rewarding local production the
communities in blue are all housing
choice communities the governor recently
announced we had 67 communities and that
represents almost 80,000 new units of
housing that got produced over the past
five years doesn't sound like a lot but
we wanted to celebrate it and celebrate
the communities that do that
this is about technical assistance and
ways in which we wanted to coordinate
all of that and really work across the
different kinds of agencies that are
part of state government delivering this
technical assistance so that there would
be no wrong front door for a musicality
the other thing we did at mass housing
was we knew that there were folks who
folks municipalities who could have a
plan but really didn't necessarily have
the right resources to turn that plan
into action and so we created a program
that we call planning for production
which we recently funded 14 projects
that promise to deliver more than 4,200
new middle-income housing units over the
next new mixed income housing unit sorry
over the next several years the other
thing we did when we walked around and
talked to municipalities was there's all
this conversation and fear about really
big projects people come in to their
community developers coming into their
communities doing two and three hundred
unit projects and so we created this
program that we call community scale
housing which is really about allowing a
local community to put up their money
the state would match that and that we
could get housing production in smaller
communities and in rural areas and in
addition and we did the workforce
housing initiative that's a hundred
million dollars of funds that mass
housing put forth with the goal of
creating a thousand new units over the
goal was to do that over four years
we've put most of the money on the
street in the past two years and are up
to about 750 units we've closed or
committed 50 7.5 million of that we've
got some more kind of soft commitments
coming that's 25 projects in 14 cities
23 hundred mixed income units and really
the program is built modeled
after the state's other kind of capital
Bond programs and serves as a subsidy
for communities to allow a different mix
in their projects this is just an
example of some projects I won't go
through that and y'all look great no
Larry one of yours is not fair
and so the other things that we're going
to be thinking about moving forward in
terms of how we continue to address this
one of which is really trying to promote
home ownership for young residents and
working families and not just promote
home ownership through homeownership
products but really be thinking about
how do we promote a homeownership
development product for this income
bracket that would be very important so
we think that instead of really trying
to figure out how to subsidize someone
who's making like I said a hundred
thousand dollars to live in a rental
unit it would be better for all of us if
we could figure out how to get them to
buy and that would free up more rental
units for and that would help drive
price down maybe the other thing as we
talked about earlier was we've got to do
something around innovations in design
and construction in Massachusetts in
particular we're kind of slow behind the
curve in terms of what those innovations
are and really trying to think about
what is the appropriate role for mass
housing to kind of bring those things
forth and what kinds of risks we should
be we would be willing to take in order
to see that happen and then thinking
about senior housing because at the end
of the day is all about me and where am
I going to live and thinking about
senior housing but not just a senior
housing product but a senior housing
product that really does integrate
service delivery and pay for that
not necessarily with housing dollars and
as we work with on the executive office
of Elder affairs
and the Secretary of HHS we really feel
like there are ways that we could be
innovative around federal funding
programs to make that happen so I think
that's it that's my story and I'm
sticking to it
[Applause]